the funeral of a russian soldier
one of so many killed during vladimir
putin's bloody advance through ukraine
we all still hope for the better that
everyone starts alive and everyone comes
home healthy alive back home
but they won't because their president
is determined to keep on fighting
committed to his own twisted narrative
that this is a battle against a neo-nazi
regime despite the fact that ukraine's
president is jewish
i will never go back on the statement
that russians and ukrainians are one
people even though a lot of ukrainians
have been threatened and brainwashed
we are fighting with the neo-nazis
they are using civilians as human
shields
those comments at a meeting with his
security council where he held a
moment's silence for russia's dead
it follows a phone call with the french
president which a french presidential
source said contained nothing reassuring
their description of that call is one of
the grimmest i've ever read vladimir
putin said he was fighting a neo-nazi
regime and that unless diplomatically
ukraine was disarmed and neutralized he
would continue his military campaign
president macron told him that this was
not a nazi regime that he was deluded
and not describing reality and that it
would cost his country dearly the source
said that vladimir putin intended to
take the whole country and that the
worst was yet to come
but russia is shrugging off the blame
for this war even as it bans its own
media from calling it one solution
the thing is the west is listening to us
but he's not hearing us and it's trying
to impose in every possible way its
understanding of how to live in europe
this begs comparisons at the time
napoleon and hitler had an objective to
have the whole of europe under their
control now americans have the whole of
europe under their control
europe is not under america's control
and neither is ukraine but those words
spring from a mindset deeply held
amongst a small group in the kremlin
which will cost ukraine europe and
russia dearly for a long long time to
come
diana magnay sky news moscow